the savviest movie stars give the people
what they want and in the late 80s the
people wanted a sort of mystical
stone-faced a martial arts expert with a
ponytail
in other words Steven Seagal he ruled
the box office for years of huge hits
like hard to kill above the law and then
the siege but tastes changed and
eventually he faded from movie star
prominence so whatever happened to
Steven Seagal he still makes lots of
movies - girl's contract with Warner
Brothers ended with the release of the
environmentally themed thriller fire
down below in 1997 he still makes action
movies though it's just that most of
them have gone straight to DVD or
streaming in fact cigars churned out
more than 30 movies in the last two
decades with awesome titles like urban
justice out for a kill and half past
dead
awesome we got a problem - cop shows one
real one fake in the late eighties
Jefferson Parish Louisiana sheriff Harry
Lee asks a goal to train his force in
martial arts
eventually enlisting Seagal as a reserve
deputy in 2009 to go sidekick became the
basis for a reality show on A&E called
Steven Seagal lawman
it was similar to cops except that
Steven Seagal was there which had to be
really weird for the criminals sadly
Seagal reportedly resigned from the
force after he found himself the subject
of an internal affairs investigation
that according to the phoenix new times
sought to uncover the truth about
allegations of sex trafficking and
sexual assault but in 2011 Seagal usul
Emmons life gave him to make lemonade
with the action series true justice
which he created and starred in as
Elijah Kane head of an elite in the
cavity Atal task force it ran for 26
episodes on the network reals before
being cancelled entrepreneur from 1999
to 2007 Seagal owned the 995 Acre
lavender farm in Northern California
where he grew the raw materials for
diamonds Lotus essentials a line of
therapeutic oils and he currently owns
an estate in California Sun tania's
Valley where he grows carbon a grape
study then sells to other wineries
[Music]
you've done well plus there Steven
Seagal's lightning bolt a line of canned
energy drinks that was proudly marketed
as the first of its kind to contain
Tibetan goji berries and Asian cordyceps
good to be the king in then hey guess
what real-life drama Seagal has been
married four times his third and most
prominent marriages with another
nostalgic icon model an actress Kelly
LeBrock most famous for being the dream
woman created by team scientists in
weird science garland LeBrock divorced
in 1996 after he reportedly had an
affair with their nanny and she got
pregnant
in 2009 he married his personal
assistant add into your bad sook but a
year later another of the girls former
personal assistant skated no Wayne sued
to go for $1,000,000 alleging he
sexually harassed and abused her those
allegations were corroborated by two
other female ex employees who alleged
similar treatment by the actor but the
suit was dropped later in the year
missed opportunities in 2007 sigalas pal
Jackie Chan is rumored to have suggested
that Seagal played the villain in rush
hour 3 after that fell through in 2010
sylvester stallone offered Seagal apart
and the action flick The Expendables
which was chock-full of 80,000 heroes
Seagal refused though due to a few do
one of the film's producers and missed
out on what would have been one of the
biggest hits of his career world citizen
bizarrely two of Siegel's friends are
Buddhist spiritual leader the Dalai Lama
and Russian President Vladimir Putin
with whom cigar is especially close he
is one of the greatest world leaders if
not the greatest world leader alive
today
in addition Seagal gained citizenship in
Serbia in January 2016 after offering to
set up a martial art studio there to go
along with his blues concerts
you probably wouldn't be able to live in
Serbia however if he followed through on
his plans to someday run for governor of
Arizona I think our biggest problem is
open borders sorry Stephen
not every problem can be solved by
kicking or whatever this is
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
which Steven Seagal movie is your
favorite Oggy
[Music]